well as you just heard hateful attacks
the pro-life movement are now normal we
just heard about what happened in
downtown Philadelphia with Pennsylvania
representative Brian Simms there's part
of it
hi everyone representative Brian Sims
here and I am outside the Planned
Parenthood a bunch of pseudo Christian
protesters who've been out here shaming
young girls for being here continues the
deal I've got $100 to anybody who will
identify any of these three to look well
today pro-life activist held a
large-scale rally outside that same a
Planned Parenthood in Philadelphia in
response to sims's behavior Abby Johnson
is a former Planned Parenthood clinic
director now a pro-life activist her
story was told in the recent film
unplanned Abby Johnson joins us Abby
thanks very much for coming on
so is it of course our imagination or is
the reaction to anti-abortion activism
including prayer turning violent it is
it's becoming increasingly violent and I
think one of the reasons is because
people in their own party the Democratic
Party are not willing to come out and
and talk about this behavior condemn
this behavior nobody from the National
Organization for Women who are supposed
to stand up for women nobody's coming
out and condemning this behavior and so
it just sort of goes unchecked and it
goes unnoticed and without consequences
and you know I I'm here to say along
with a thousand other pro-lifers who
were there today to say this is enough
we've had enough we're not going to be
bullied we're not going to be harassed
we're out there this is within our First
Amendment right to do so what do you
think is dry I mean what do you think is
driving this these are people who are
arguing for abortion in some cases post
viability late term abortion not only
they're not ashamed of that position but
they want to hurt anyone who disagrees
why do you think where does that come
from
that impulse
well so I think it's a couple things I
think right now abortion supporters are
they're feeling the heat they're feeling
the pressure we've got these heartbeat
bills being signed all across the
country we have pro-life measures taking
place in in many many different states I
think that now we have a Supreme Court
that's being set up to overturn roe v
wade so I think in in some ways it's a
response to to the sort of impending
doom that they feel that Roe might one
day actually be overturned but I think
also you know we've got over 60 million
abortions on the books recorded since
Roe was passed in 1973 and you know
we're dealing with a group of people who
are very wounded they're very hurt and
they need to really justify their own
actions and and a lot of times that hurt
comes across as anger and they just
don't see the difference I think it's
exactly right when you know you're wrong
that's when you're the maddest that's
how I am I think that's how most people
are it's it said Abby thank you very
much of course thank you